what a lot of us do is we go into an
environment we wait until we see someone
that we're attracted to and then we
obsess over what the hell we would say
if we tried to talk to that person and
now we spend the whole
time that we're there becoming more and
more nervous they become this projection
that is so removed from what we actually
know about them right now which is we
just saw an attractive person most
people when they go to any environment
they're either alone or they're with one
or two friends outside of those one or
two friends they're going to talk to the
person they've already had some small
interaction with that became a kind of
green light for a natural or organic
exchange if you've had the natural or
organic exchange with someone you're
gonna find that a some interactions just
gravitate back to you an hour later or
two hours later B even if you're the one
who initiates you already have that
initial interaction to go by
foreign